don lemon man this is a person who
considers himself to be
an objective journalist he he says this
he continues to maintain this he'll say
i'm an objective journalist i'm just
giving my perspective
which means that you're not objective so
he had on his show
one of the police officers who testified
in front of congress during the january
6th
hearing this is the police officer who
happened to
suggest that america was congenitally
racist and naturally racist because the
people
who are attempting to beat him up or
shouting racist things and don lemon
sort of lets the cat out of the bag here
because a lot of people on the right
have been saying
yeah january 6th was quite terrible it
was a riot and the people
who participated in it should go to jail
now folks on the left what say you about
all the riots from last year where you
were you know bailing people out of
prison and where five billion dollars in
property damage was done only two
billion dollars insured
and where many people were killed what
do you have to say about that
and don lemon's take on this is i think
pretty much
how the left thinks about nearly
everything it's pretty wild here is don
lemon we can deal with many things in
this country
at the same time and if something
happens it doesn't mean that you go
oh what about this what about that can
we focus on what happened on january 6
where our democracy
was in jeopardy we should be this is
this weren't just people who were
who were exercising um some of them were
exercising
their right to protest others went way
too far
that's a different story than trying to
undermine democracy and stop an election
that's unbelievable right basically you
know there were some people at the blm
protests who just they went too far
it happens you know they you know that
that's not the same thing as some people
who went too far by invading the capitol
building
so these most of those people are just
exercising their rights and then
they just got a little bit you know
overzealous and they burned down a cop
a cop car and they set a police station
on fire and they invaded a federal
courthouse in portland
you know that's just stuff that happens
it's not an insurrection i mean that's
not
like is that really something we should
worry about here's the thing about the
left
there's no one who's too left-wing for
the left people who are too left-wing
for the left
are all people who are just too
energetic they're just
too wedded to their own principles but
the people who are too left-wing for the
left like
even politically speaking when is the
last time you saw the democratic party
say
you know this communist over here he
really is not one of us i don't like
what he's doing here
this is really bad it's never that it's
always they're naive
you know they're not it's it's there and
i have a and their purity of heart that
the problem is they're too pure
right aoc bernie sanders the problem is
they're too pure
they don't understand the realities of
politics but you have to admire their
purity don't you
that's on the political level on the
level of violence it's you know those
people who are attacking police officers
and shutting down cities for
weeks on end and rioting and looting
those are just people who've gotten a
little bit out over their ski
you know they've got the right
principles they believe the right things
it's just that they they don't know how
to control it and and really we have to
have sympathy for them
meanwhile the folks on january 6. those
are those are inherently bad people
because those people believed bad things
and said bad things
we'll get some more of the craziness in
just one second first
how did you choose which isp to use the
sad thing is most of us have very little
choice because internet service
providers operate like monopolies in the
regions they serve
then use that monopoly power to take
advantage of customers many isps
log your internet activity and sell that
data on to other big tech companies or
advertisers
to prevent isps from seeing my internet
activity i protect
all my devices with expressvpn it's a
simple app for your computer or
smartphone
that encrypts all your network data and
tunnels it through a secure vpn server
just download the app you tap one button
on your device
now you're protected watch here it is
it's on my phone see this
right here i hit this button blink and
now
connected it is indeed that simple and
expressvpn does all of that without
slowing
your connection that's why it's rated
the number one vpn service by cnet and
wired
so stop handing over your personal data
to isps and other tech giants who mine
your activity and then sell off your
info
protect yourself with the vpn i trust to
keep me private online visit
expressvpn.com to get three extra months
for free if you ever wonder whether cnn
and don lemon
whether they are poo pooing the sorts of
violence that we saw all of last summer
the answer is yes they are papooing that
sort of violence
this is why what they call what about
ism
very often i just call having a standard
it's not what about ism
if i say that january 6th was really bad
and also i'm noticing that you're not
treating january 6th in the same way
that you treated the riots last summer
so what is your standard i know what my
standard is
violence in pursuit of political ends is
bad
regardless of the political end that is
my standard
and we can argue about the merits or
demerits of the political ends at stake
i think that both the the folks who were
rioting on january 6th
and the folks who were rioting last
summer i think both of their causes were
bad
and untrue but at least i have a
standard an objective standard of what
is right and wrong zomlima has no such
standard
for him it's the cause that defines the
standard that is acceptable
if you are if you are fighting against
systemic racism
then you get to steal a tv or at the
very least if you steal a tv we
understand where you're coming from
but if you're a person who is protesting
the election and you break into the
capitol building
that makes you an actor of unique evil
that's kind of an amazing thing it
really especially coming from captain
objective news journalist over here and
then back to the political level you see
this all the time with regard to the
left
if they go too far well it was all in
the pursuit of decent to end
again my question is what would you
consider totalitarian so if donald trump
were to come out tomorrow and say if
he'd been president
you know and during his presidency
president trump had said
we're masking up everybody vaccinated
and unmasked and unvaccinated
if he had said that the left likely
would have deemed that authoritarian
if joe biden does it it seems a
wonderful exercise of police power
you have to have some sort of consistent
standard as to what authoritarianism
constitutes or what radicalism
constitutes
or what violence constitutes but but
again the standards are meant
not to apply because it's all a power
game when we do it it's good and when
you do it it's bad
that's the standard and so long as
that's the standard we can't have
anything remotely approaching a normal
political conversation
because we can't even agree on what is
out of bounds and what is not out of
bounds apparently
and that really is dangerous hey guys
quick note my brand new book the
authoritarian moment is out
this week go pick up a copy today i
think it's really important
it's about how all of the major
institutions of american society have
now been
taken over and weaponized by the left
against dissent
it's not just about how they did it it's
about how we take those institutions
back
check out the link in the description
below and get a copy of the
authoritarian moment